cette guerre a un lourd passif est ici à
pithiviers qu'on transiter une partie et
des 13000 juifs déportés en 1942 vers
les camps d'extermination pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
80 ans après la rafle du vel d'hiv la
france rend hommage aux victimes dans
l'ancienne gare le président rappelle
que le combat contre l'antisémitisme
n'est pas terminée nous devons faire le
constat lucide
cet antisémitisme est même encore plus
brûlant rang tant qu'il ne l'était en
1995 dans notre pays en europe et dans
tant d'endroits du monde en 1942 des
policiers et des gendarmes français
avaient participé aux arrestations de
juifs le président jacques chirac a été
le premier à reconnaître la
responsabilité de son pays dans les
déportations
la première ministre de la france a
dénoncé le silence des autorités
françaises pendant 50 ans notre pays a
attendu 1995 et les mots du président
jacques chirac
1995 il y a moins de 30 ans pour
reconnaître sa responsabilité et la
vérité
hamon rien cet anniversaire j'ai revivre
de douloureux souvenirs à georgette
greenberg cette survivante avait trois
ans au moment de la rafle de seule chose
que je me rappelle réellement c'est de
tenir la main de ma mère est de crier
parce que je voulais ma mère sa mère a
été transporté à auschwitz où elle est
morte avec sa soeur georgette greenberg
a réussi à éviter ce même destin elles
se sont enfuies et une famille française
les ont cachés pendant quatre ans il
faut que la jeunesse h pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas ça peut se reproduire
mais espérons que ça se reproduira
jamais depuis son arrivée au canada en
1955 georgette greenberg se donne la
mission d'éduquer les jeunes en faisant
des discours dans les écoles ici charles
du boullay radio canada montréal